donc là on est en train de passer une
loi
qui cet automne va être votée qui va
permettre maintenant si je puis dire
d'éloigner en ligne les cyber-harceleurs
en les interdisant de réseau pendant 6
mois si c'est reproduise pendant 12 mois
et ça concerne légènes les adultes tout
le monde ils peuvent pas recréer de
compte c'est la responsabilité du réseau
de l'exclure pendant 6 mois s'il recrée
par d'autres voix
un autre compte et que il reprend ses
activités de harcèlement à ce moment-là
la sanction et la pénalité ira au réseau
quand les responsabilise c'est la
directive européenne qui nous permet de
faire c'est la responsabilité aussi des
réseaux d'appliquer cette loi si elle
est votée
s'ils le font pas beaucoup de choses ont
été faites ces dernières années c'est un
combat absolument majeur parce qu'il est
il est terrible pour pour les enfants
les ados et les jeunes qui le vivent et
donc on lâchera rien